mettez-les et
remettez-les ne me les
donnez pas donnez-les moi d'
accord vous savez ce que cela a été l'
affichage le plus enfantin des forces de l'
ordre que j'ai jamais vu d'
accord je n'ai aucune idée de ce que c'était que
vous venez de dire
que vous devenez plus froid  ouais
oh c'est pour toi
regarde ce qu'elle te donne tu lui donnes
elle lui donne
le cadeau elle lui donne regarde le
regarde regarde le te le donne et
je vais au bar
quelques années au même gars ouais  ouais
était-il un homme entendant
bonne nuit
hé
hé d'
accord jésus
plat de pétri et canapé oh tire je voulais que
tu sois confortable
est-ce que je serais confortable mon pied est ici
qui me rendra vraiment confortable ne me pousse
pas don  ne me fais pas caca
oh attends hé hé
bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle j'ai trouvé ces boules
ils avaient un sac clair de
rien tu es le
bienvenu mec elle vient d'avoir un bébé ça a
été ça a été une période difficile j'ai vu la
naissance ce n'était pas si difficile  sur toi le
travail était vraiment dur c'était la première
fois que je voyais ça oh ouais
et c'est un peu  effets la façon dont vous en
sortez allez que faites-vous pour la
porte sortez de la voiture poussez simplement la
butée de porte je peux déverrouiller la porte pour vous
ici
quel est votre problème
hé regardez j'ai votre ami ouais vous
devriez commencer  traîner je vais essayer de
vous mettre dans une pièce ensemble en train de travailler dessus
ouais tais-toi ferme ta bouche hé femme je
t'ai déjà dit que je ne connais même pas ces
filles je me tiens juste dans ce coin et fais
mes séductions oh tout d'abord  c'est du
sudoku juste pour traîner là où sont toutes les
prostituées tu fais juste une sorte de type
de bonne volonté
comme ce gars qui cherche juste les
prostituées
tu as un vrai coeur d'or rojas
tu ne parles pas de prostituée
prostituée je pensais qu'ils voulaient sortir avec
nous quelque chose essayant de faire l'amour
je ne sais pas pourquoi vous êtes tous obsédés
par moi essayant de faire tomber un jeune
homme noir qui a réussi vous n'êtes
rien d'autre qu'un raciste oui
ne tirez pas ça  taureau raciste avec moi neuf
gars sur dix avec qui j'ai des relations
sexuelles  h sont des gars noirs donc il y a votre
théorie hein
prêt ajoutez de l'action
hey marque
b marque d
marque vous emmène de l'autre côté